so tell me a little bit about the bend
yeah yeah so the band basically evolved
out of my choir directing experience
we're from Detroit basically a family
group my wife and I are the proud
parents of nine children and they kind
of grew up around me directing choirs we
started the Boys Choir Detroit and the
Girls Choir of Detroit and when we came
to New York about almost ten years after
the founding of the children's choirs we
started to branch out on our own and
have like our family choir night so we
started in Central Park like a night in
2007 so this is literally our eighth
season performing in the park
yo what's up a screen I'm out here
Bethesda Fountain Central Park Easter
Sunday I'm about to give a bunch of
money to a street musician that I
sampled it feels damn good I got to say
basically my boy Chris D'Elia asked me
to do the music for his comedy special
on Netflix
and I wanted to make it alive from the
streets thing so I sampled these people
and I got a some money I want to give it
to live from the streets alright so yeah
I met you guys I think it was in July or
something I came out here reported a
bunch of stuff and then I I turned it
into a Pete
do the intro music for his comedy
special on Netflix you know I told your
cops about it I want to give you guys
half the money that I got paid
thanks love thanks for let's do it man
have some Oreo my first weeks
so I think a lot coming from you never
again
so you glad you are on the show yeah
laughing screech the album's do